did russia just turn off the spigot on
europe moscow has announced sanctions on
31 european companies including gas prom
germania the former subsidiary of
russian gas giant gas prom that is now
controlled by german regulators as well
as germany's biggest gas storage
facility and gas trader wind gas economy
minister robert habeck on thursday
confirmed that some companies are no
longer receiving gas due to the
sanctions though he said the country has
found alternative suppliers
now for more on this i'm joined now by
henning glory stein the director of
energy climate and resources at eurasia
group in london henning thanks for being
here
so
what do you make of this we've already
seen russia cut off bowling and bulgaria
is this the moment when russia cuts off
the rest of europe from its gas
um thanks for having me it's probably
not that moment yet but
the
sort of the deterioration of security of
supply from russia is really quite
alarming we're seeing a steady uh sort
of escalation of sanctions retallery
sanctions
and um just last night's announcement
that russia had imposed um sanctions on
gas from germania and uh poland's part
of the yama pipeline just really doesn't
it means that we don't quite know if or
when russia will uh cut gas supply
that means the european union must do
absolutely everything to secure
alternative supplies so that we have gas
next winter
yeah the eu had expected not to be fully
off russian gas for years they said
sometimes sometime before 2030. um is
the eu at all prepared for this
well so uh three months ago they weren't
at all uh prepared for this in any way
uh two months ago a little bit
and now they are going into overdrive to
prepare for this so i think a bit like
you've seen in oil um over recent weeks
there's a lot of movement there's a lot
of action going on alternative supply
contracts lng import terminals floating
vessels being shipped to europe so that
they prepare for next winter but it's i
mean if russian gas stops flowing
entirely it's going to be really tight
and there might be um
some
some rationing of energy in the worst
case next winter we just don't know
sadly
yeah what would the impacts be prices
have already skyrocketed you mentioned
rationing there what what are the
effects if russia does cut off
gas well so i mean right now prices are
actually not that bad because we're just
out of winter there's no heating demand
now so and there's a lot of lmg coming
in that was bought at super high prices
a few months ago uh but uh once it gets
cold again and if there's a disruption
um from of russian gas supply especially
on a big scale you know total cut-off
for instance then prices would go
through the roof again and in a worse
case um i mean for instance the german
government would have to um go from its
current level one of the gas emergency
to the maximum level which would involve
a
rationing of energy to non uh
non-essential industries so that uh they
can secure your supply of of social
services health services and of course
um home heating and electricity so that
would and that would be uh pretty rough
for germany and the economy and for
people
and in glory stein the director of
energy climate and resources at eurasia
group thanks so much for joining us
thank you